Daniel: Hello and welcome everyone.
This is ActInf GuestStream 15.3, lucky
number three with Bobby!
We're here with Bobby Azarian as well as
some guests.
We're going to have a discussion, talk
about a range of different topics.
It's June 1 2023 1st, Adam and Michael
can intro introduce themselves.
Then Bobby will pass it off to you for
sharing your screen and facilitating this
however you see fit.
So Adam, go for it.
Adam: Hello I'm Adam, I am a research
fellow at the Johns Hopkins Center for
Psychedelic and Consciousness Research.
Long standing interest in the free energy
principle, consciousness, free will,
psychedelics, artificial intelligence and
along the way I met and befriended Bobby
and I guess proud to be part of the
movement.
Bobby: Thanks for coming Adam.
Yeah, Adam I wish we would have time to
get into this today but Adam has
presented a pretty clear mechanistic
model of free will, cybernetic free will.
.
And there's just this huge problem where
and I'll keep this short, we got to
introduce Michael, but basically the main
kind of straw man against free will is
that there's this argument that you have
this nonphysical mind doing stuff outside
of causality and that's why everyone's
rejecting it as not a scientific idea.
But of course something can't work if it
doesn't have mechanism.
If it's not real, it's not real.
So it's kind of a ridiculous debate to
have if you want to talk about what
people are talking about when they
discuss free will.
In the past we didn't have mechanisms to
understand what that was, but now we
understand things like top down causation,
, we understand control and when you have
that language you can actually talk about
what free will is in a mechanistic way
and that just changes the debate
completely.
That's not enough to convince people that
there's something called free will
because there's a lot of issues that we
get into.
But Adam's one of the people that have
been taking this nebulous concept and
have been trying to show that there's
actually a very specific set of
mechanisms and it's nothing outside of
science but it is science that is outside
of our current paradigm.
It's just dynamics that we don't normally
that weren't included in the previous
model so it looked like magic but there's
stuff going on there.
So yeah, we're going to have a longer
discussion with Adam in the future either
on my channel or maybe we'll come back
and make it all about free will because
it's such a big topic.
But yeah, thanks for coming and invite
Michael as well.
Yes.
Michael: Am I supposed to take the wheel
now?
Yeah.
Obviously, I'm a fan of Bobby's.
I very much like well, I think it's
important, I think, the work that Bobby
is trying to articulate.
And Adam, I'm a fan, so this is the first
time we've met, but I've watched some of
your stuff as well.
And Daniel, obviously, we've talked, and
yeah, let's just yield to Bobby.
And let's see where we go here.
Bobby: Yeah.
Michael has a background in kind of
system science and those kind of things.
That's how we kind of resonate is kind of
like the system science approach, but
thinking about how system science can be
applied to psychology and organizational
issues.
So how to make this stuff that's very
theoretical practical.
And so we're kind of working on that on
the side.
And then Brennan Grand MC will be coming
and joining the conversation.
Since he's not here right now, I'll just
give a little introduction for him.
He's the author of a book called
emergentism, and he has a Facebook group
called Metamodern Spirituality.
And basically in that book, he's turned
this emergence paradigm, which is
basically kind of the opposite of the
reductionist paradigm, into something
like a sort of secular religion.
So he's talking about a lot of these same
things.
So he'll join us shortly, probably.
I think he's watching the stream and is
trying to get into the zoom link.
So yeah, we can start.
It'd be great for this to be sort of a
discussion.
So if anything I say triggers any sort of
thoughts or criticisms, please speak up,
because I don't have an organized set of
slides and there's a lot to talk about.
And the problem really, when I was trying
to make these slides was like, everything
I say kind of gets into something else.
And so I had, like 100 slides, and I was
just trying to organize them in the last
minute.
So I think I have some slides that were
made in the past for other presentations
that are just going to be kind of like a
roadmap, but we can veer off of that.
And I'm going to be saying a lot of stuff
that's not in the slides.
Yeah, so I guess we can start.
So I'll share my screen because I just
shared my screen from my computer and I
couldn't see you.
But I think the trick to that is to share
my screen through zoom and then share do,
like, slideshow, and then I should be
able to see your faces on the side.
Yes.
Okay, so you can see my screen now, then
if I do slideshow, it doesn't perfect.
Okay.
Michael: Bobby, just before you get
started, I believe Brendan joined us as
well.
Bobby: Hey, Brendan!
Daniel: We warmed up the crowd.
Bobby: His audio yeah, his audio is
probably not connected yet, so we can
just begin.
Hey, Brendan, I introduced you, and I.
Brendan: Was just set on the YouTube
version, and then I got the link, so
great.
It's a pleasure to be here.
Thanks for thanks for the introduction.
I appreciate it.
Bobby: Yeah, no problem.
Please feel free to chime in at any time
because I really need help here.
I'm not prepared to do this by myself.
And maybe you can play the role of the
critic, too, because I should have
invited some anti free will people or
just some skeptics of these ideas,
because what I realized is, like, I'm
saying these things, a lot of them were
the things in my book The Romance of
Reality.
And I make that argument as clear as I
can.
But then people have criticisms that, for
whatever reason, how I worded it, don't
address those, and then they're not
convinced.
And then I do nothing to convince anyone
who doesn't already believe this.
So it's actually a lot more fruitful if
there's sort of this dialectical debate
like this dynamic, because then you hear
both sides and then I can actually
address the things that people think are
the issues that might cast out on some of
the things that I'm arguing.
The teleological stance.
So this is the name of the self help
system, for lack of a better term.
I know people hear self help and they
think that's something like Cheesy and
New Age or BS.
And there are a lot of snake oil salesmen
in this place.
And I think that's why it's so important
that we try, if possible, to create
something like a self help system and
something almost like a religion, like
something that has practices and a sort
of instruction manual for a living based
on scientific principles.
Now, it doesn't have to be based on
science, won't explain everything or
address everything.
But this provides a foundation where we
can actually start to build logic, where
we can go, some of these things are right
and some of these things aren't.
And we can start to see things that have
been said in folk psychology or New Age
practices that people just considered to
be non scientific or pseudoscience.
We can see how that maps on to some of
these newer mechanisms that we're
understanding, because now we're starting
to look at biology and neuroscience and
psychology from the perspective of
information theory and thermodynamics.
And these are revealing new mechanisms
that I believe can create a bridge
between reductionist science and the
higher sciences.
But also a lot of these statements you'll
hear things that you hear in, like,
spiritual circles or people are doing
practices, just different little things
that they find to be very effective.
In most cases, there's a scientific
explanation for why those things are
effective.
And most science minded people are
ignoring all that stuff.
So they're like throwing out all of these
things that emerged because they were
adaptations, like practices, community
building, things like that are just
completely being ignored.
And that's really bad.
It's just throwing the baby out with the
bathwater.
And as long as we have that mentality
scientists, they may say, I don't want to
promote religion, organized religion, let'
's say, or like kind of New Age
spirituality, I don't want to promote
that.
But they're actually helping keep those
things in existence because a lot of
regular people are hearing this
scientific worldview that's the
mainstream worldview, and it's very
nihilistic in some of its beliefs, and
that'd be okay if that's how reality was.
.
But we're going to see that a lot of
these are based on mistaken assumptions
and people are rejecting that worldview
because it doesn't offer anything of
value to them as a normal person.
And they will opt for other less evidence
based worldviews or philosophies because
they're not getting that from that.
So science is actually helping, like
pseudoscience and things like that, if
they want to keep science isolated from
all these practical things and sort of
addressing bigger existential and even
spiritual questions.
And so if we can do that, if we can build
that bridge, it would be good for
unifying everyone.
But it would also cut down on a lot of
the pseudoscience and stuff that people
are trying to kind of prevent from not
going there.
But actually, I think that's part of the
problem, if that makes any sense.
So this is stuff from my substac Road to
Omega.
Go there and check it out.
There's posts on the teleological stance
that break this down in more detail than
I'll be able to give here today.
I have this word in this slide poetic
meta Naturalism.
If you're familiar with my book, you
might have seen that it's not really
important to really talk about why I call
it that, but let's just say there are
these two distinctive worldviews.
So there's the old mainstream scientific
worldview, which is the reductionist
worldview, which I think is basically a
nihilistic worldview.
And there are a lot of assumptions built
into this worldview based on just we had
limited knowledge at the time of how the
world works.
So there were things like, for example,
when we thought the world was Newtonian,
you just couldn't get away from
determinism this kind of strict Laplacian
determinism.
Laplace basically took Newton's kind of
framework and tried to apply it to
everything.
It's really interesting that Newton
himself didn't do that.
He didn't think that his laws applied to
life.
And Newton was actually very religious
and thought there were all these crazy
hidden messages in the Bible, which is
neat and kind of like covered up because
people don't want people to know that
Newton was so religious.
So Laplace kind of created this
deterministic philosophy.
And when we thought that was the truth,
then there was no room for human agency.
There was just one future trajectory and
we couldn't do anything to change that.
And we weren't really doing anything to
begin with.
Everything we do is sort of illusory and
we can talk about determinism in greater
detail, but that's one nihilistic aspect
is that we don't have any agency and we
don't have free will.
Brendan: Free will?
Bobby: It's a bit more of a loaded term.
There's just assumptions with that word,
like with the word free that make it a
little bit more of a contentious subject.
.
But yeah, with determinism in the strict
sense, no one could have any agency.
So if you accept that scientific
proposition, then you're like basically
accepting that you have no control over
the future or your life.
And that can be very depressing and
demotivating.
And there are studies that we can talk
about that have shown that that belief
actually causes people to, for example,
behave less morally.
They will be more likely to cheat because
they don't have culpability because no
one's responsible for anything.
That's them basically choosing to not
have this agency that I'll explain
exactly what I mean by that.
But basically, I mean the fact that you
can tell them that and then they lose it
and then they start behaving more
immorally.
It's obvious that there's something
causal there that's changing their
behavior.
So that's kind of a clue that that
picture something doesn't make sense
there.
And it also causes people to be really
depressed and have kind of existential
meltdowns.
I personally had when I thought
determinism was the only explanation that
made sense.
I sort of had times where I would have
these experiences where I was very
disturbed by the fact that I had no
control over anything and that this was
sort of a tape that was determined from
the initial event and that I was just
playing that out.
It can be very disturbing if you take
this stuff seriously.
And what I'm arguing is that a lot of the
scientists preaching this stuff, they're
not taking it seriously because they can'
't.
Your life would just be over if you
really believe that you had no agency
because you would stop doing stuff.
Adam: I tried to take it seriously and it
took me out for a good two years.
Bobby: How do you even take it
seriously?
What does that do?
What do you do
then?
Adam: It happened.
It was a combination of reading this book,
, “The Meme Machine” by Susan Blackmore
and “Darwin's.
Dangerous Idea.”
There was this one sentence that just
took me out.
It was like everything up to this moment,
including your genes, environment, and
all your experiences, including the first
half of this sentence, will determine how
you interpret the second half.
It was sort of like just this web of
causation being described on a different
level of analysis.
Sort of like bringing that to the
foreground and not seeing me in that
foreground.
And then I was like, oh, there isn't like
a neuron in my brain that knows or cares
that I exist as whole.
And that was, wait, not even sodium ions
are going to sodium ion.
They're just going to follow those
gradients.
Oh, God.
It just sort of had me for a while.
Bobby: Does it kind of paralyze you or
did you just go, I'm going to do what I
was going to do anyway, but I'm going to
do it, I'm going to have this weird sort
of experience at the same time because it'
's all meaningless.
I'm just going to go through life.
I'm probably going to look really sad,
but I'm going to do everything that I
plan to do otherwise?
Or does it just shut you down where you'
're like, I'm not going to get out of
bed?
Adam: There was kind of like a double
consciousness about it too, because it
was like, I'd be moving between having
that as a frame, but then to take action,
you can't you can't you just.
Bobby: Got to throw it out the window.
Adam: On occasion, there would be kind of
like a maybe this I don't think it took
me in an unethical direction, but kind of
like a fracket mindset.
Like, well, nothing matters anyway, so
woo.
Bobby: Yeah, really stick for me.
Brendan: Can I offer a devil's advocate
take here?
And I don't know if we're derailing.
Bobby: Or no, this is perfect, this is
great.
Brendan: And it is very much a devil's
advocate position because I think, Bobby,
you and I are very much aligned on trying
to emphasize the importance of free will,
the causal power of information,
potentially, et cetera.
I'm sure you might get into some of that,
but I will say this in its favor or in
addition to what's being said.
So I also had an experience like that of
suffering from the seeming implications
of the deterministic universe.
But I do think that there's a way of also
allowing all of that to be the case and
responding differently.
And there are a number of different ways
that that can look, I mean, there's the
Nietzsche approach to this which is
actually kind of taking this
deterministic cycle and kind of the
eternal recurrence of the same as sort of
a wild yes saying to existence, and I'll
just throw that out there and bracket it.
.
We could come back to that one.
Bobby: What do you mean by that?
Sorry.
Brendan: Nietzsche was he would
philosophize while walking or he would
think his philosophy while going on these
long walks and everything, right?
And one day he was walking in the Swiss
Alps and he sees this gigantic rock and
he comes to this sudden realization and I
guess I won't get into the whole story
because it would probably be a little bit
too much.
But basically the realization that
springs there, which he has at this sort
of monolithic scene, is somehow he sort
of transported and appreciates that what
he would need to do was affirm his
existence under the assumption that
everything that has happened and will
happen, will happen over and over and
over again for eternity.
All the mistakes, all the ecstasies, et
cetera.
It was all there almost.
You could kind of think of it kind of in
the there's the Big Bang, big crunch
model and then it repeats.
And so let's say something like that.
Bobby: Is happening, where yeah, he
called it eternal recurrence.
Brendan: Right, yeah, eternal recurrence.
.
And he basically said that we need to be
able to positively affirm that in an
exuberant sense.
Bobby: What does that mean?
Brendan: Well, what it means is that if
you take the idea seriously that this is
your life and you are therefore radically
responsible in some ways for what you
experience.
And I'll come back to this in the sense
of what responsibility could mean in this
context as well, then it actually imbues
everything with an incredible
significance because this is what you'll
be experiencing over and over again.
The second thing I wanted to say, which I
think might kind of preempt some of your
kind of like, well, how does that work?
Right?
How can you be responsible?
Is I do think that there's a
phenomenological way that you can come to
terms with determinism that basically
concludes something like, okay, even if
mechanistically this can be describable
in terms of deterministic, cause and
effect all the way back.
My experience of it is rather different.
I have the experience of free will.
I feel as though as if I can choose as I
want to.
And so there is no necessary reason why
some descriptive framework needs to
impinge upon my own phenomenological
sense of reality.
So for a long time I made peace with this
question that way by basically saying,
yeah, it's all determined, but I feel as
though I have free will.
And that's really, I think, the core
there because let me say something about.
.
Bobby: That and I don't want it to seem
dismissive, but I mean, this is not your
idea anyway, so I don't really have to
apologize to you.
It's Nietzsche, and it's one of the
possible things that I think you're
considering.
But we've talked about this.
I think we have similar ideas about
agency.
What I want to say about that is
basically that is similar to
compatibilism.
And what's going on is that these people
are there's language games.
First of all, if you believe that causal
story in the strict sense and it's more
complicated that because I'm saying that
there is causality.
There's always cause and effect to
everything and that doesn't not permit
agency.
But what I'm going to say is the kind of
magic ingredient to understanding how
this can be mechanistic idea or
mechanistic process, how free will can be
explained as part of the causal chain.
We need to talk about top down causation
and that's really the game changer.
But without top down causation, I don't
think there is any responsibility.
And what I think that Nietzsche and
others are doing is, first of all, they'
're compartmentalizing.
They're not fully taking the determinism
they're talking about seriously.
And if you do that, you have to
compartmentalize if you believe that
because like Adam said, you have to throw
that out when you actually want to take
action.
So first of all, everybody who believes
in determinism is kind of living a split
personality life and that leads to all
kinds of cognitive dissonance.
But it's worse than that.
You still are in a way.
Adam: It depends.
I'm agnostic about determinism in terms
of like that was part of, but it wasn't
agnosticism about determinism, but going
more deflationary on causation or more
instrumentalist on causation.
Bobby: And I do think that I'm open.
Adam: To there being a best causal
handling, or there could be like a new
Gestalt for me where causation kind of
enters into physics and full majesty and.
.
Bobby: That'S what this is.
That's what I want to describe.
Adam: But the move for me was
compatibilism via instrumental causation.
.
That kind of stays within Carol's, like
it stays in its lane.
Bobby: Yes, I will put out a thing out
there where you could have determinism
and have true agency too.
At these higher levels, you would still
need top down causation, but you might
not need any indeterminism at the most
fundamental level, like quantum
indeterminism, and you could still have
potentially agency and that's sort of
Adam's perspective or like he says, he's
agnostic on it.
But in the future, I hope to convince
Adam that there's a better solution.
What I was saying to Brendan is that
these are language games when he's like,
it's truly this way, it's this way, but
that should make you feel like you're
responsible because this is the life you
have and the one you're going to repair
or whatever.
It's good reasoning.
Brian Green says similar stuff and that's
why I say this.
Brian Green is like, the decision is real,
, but it's not really you making it, but
it's a real, like a lot of strange, weird
language games that if you actually make
language the focus, which I wanted to do,
but it's way too abstract.
Like, I didn't have time to nail that
down for today, but that's what I want to
do in the future.
And you can show that people who are
talking about this stuff, especially
people who are trying to find some sort
of silver lining to determinism, they're
using words inconsistently.
They will use a word one way and then
contradict it.
They might even use the same word in two
different ways in the same sentence.
But basically you can't have well, I'm
going to let you respond, Brendan, but I
don't think there can be in that model
any true responsibility and then this
solution of like, but I feel like I have
it, to me, it doesn't give you anything
additional.
Like, you're just an epic phenomenon.
And to me that can be almost worse.
He's given a nice spin on the positive
way you can see it, but there's other
people, like illusionists, that say, yeah,
, we have this phenomenal experience.
It feels like I have free will, but there'
's absolutely no responsibility.
Like, Sam Harris was like, I don't have
pride.
A friend was just talking to me about
this because he's a Sam Harris fan, but
he is turned off by this whole no free
will thing.
And then he hears Sam Harris contradict
himself all the time because Sam Harris
will say, you don't have free will.
And the whole thing is on free will.
And then there's a little commercial for
his podcast where he goes, you have the
freedom to choose to listen to this
podcast.
It's like you're using double talk, like,
constantly.
Adam: I think it's very notable.
Sam Harris does not tell that to.
Bobby: His daughter, and he says that
they.
Adam: Say it to each other.
Bobby: He says, I'm not going to tell my
kids because it's going to make them
behave differently and like all these bad
things that I said.
But when they grow up, I'll tell them
that they don't have any agency when they'
're ready for it.
But what I'm saying is all of that is
absolutely ridiculous talk.
It's absolutely nonsense to be like, she
doesn't have age, I'm not going to tell
everything he's doing.
The whole argument is completely self
defeating in every way, and there's a lot
of people that have tried to make nice
stories out of it, but ultimately they're
contradicting themselves.
And compatibilism in its current form is
a contradiction.
And people call it out for that all the
time, but that doesn't stop the
compatibleists because it seems like the
best answer.
It goes, yeah, but I experience this
agency, so it has to be real on some
level.
But then how can we go against this
determinism?
It seems to go against causality in
general.
So it's like a lot of people like Dan
didn't.
Their solution was like, I'm not going to
go against these sorts of like, I'm not
going to go against determinism or
causality, which I'm saying it doesn't go
against causality, but they think the
best solution is to try to do some magic
and make both these things work together.
.
Yeah.
So we can talk more about that, but yeah.
.
Brandy, may I maybe you have a response
to that, please?
Michael: Yeah, I was just going to throw
in something that we had grounded this in
before was the idea that we choose not to
act on the back of that.
Right.
So there's that balance of you know what
I'm talking about, right?
Bobby: Yeah.
If you believe that it's going to affect
your behavior, too.
And what I'm going to argue is that you
won't exercise your agency as much as you
would if you don't believe it.
Adam: Along those lines, part of what
really concerns me about the anti free
will rhetoric is because an agency active
inference that Carl sometimes say there's
certain optimism that's required, that's
just built into it for the way you pursue
goals by predicting them into being.
And so if you stop believing in yourself
as a cause, being able to predict certain
goals, that actually could be a real
problem.
Bobby: I believe it is a real problem and
that actually these people living this
are already not behaving optimally, not
making decisions optimally.
Here's the thing, though.
You may say Sam Harris is a really
successful guy.
How do you explain that?
It's because he's living, too.
He has a split personality.
The part of him that pumped about doing
all this stuff, it's disconnected from
the part of him that really believes that
he has no agency.
And you've seen that in those studies
where you see people lose that belief and
it changes their behavior.
So my point is, if that's the way reality
is, then we have to tell the truth.
And that's what Sam Harris says.
I'm not going to sugarcoat it for you,
but what I'm saying is that idea is built
on a mountain of language ambiguities
that are creating this problem and just a
misunderstanding of causation.
Because if you think all causation is
bottom up, which means that the system is
not, there's no higher level control.
And this is kind of getting into details
that I need to give some more background
for, but if it's all bottom up causation,
then there is no room for agency.
But if you have top down causation and
the whole system is this control center,
it's a cybernetic control system that's
basically we can explain this later, but
what I will argue is that the
evolutionary process accumulates
knowledge.
So adaptive information in biological
systems, so predictive information about
the environment, the knowledge, the
adaptations that are being acquired
through evolution correspond to genes and
neural connections that basically encode
information about the external world.
And that's what starts to give a system
agency.
And that's why living systems behave
differently than inanimate systems.
And that is because the system has gained
causal power.
So the system as a coherent unit is
starting to control the components that
it's made of and the trajectory that the
system follows.
And so for example, Philip Ball is a
journalist who's been writing about this
a lot like one of the most respected
science journalists.
But if you drop a pigeon and a rock off a
tower, the rock you can predict with
Newtonian mechanics, with classical
physics equations, you can predict the
trajectory of the rock, you can't predict
the trajectory of the bird.
So there's something fundamentally
different about those two things.
And I'm saying that behavioral
distinction is what we have to call
agency.
Now, that doesn't get us to free will,
but it shows us that there's some sort of
causal difference between biological
systems and inanimate systems.
And this used to be attributed to
vitalism.
What I'm saying is that vitalism wasn't
necessarily wrong, we just didn't know
what that vital force was.
And now we have a name for it and we call
it information.
So I kind of veered from the point maybe,
but yeah, I can't remember what I was
answering with that.
Brendan, do you have anything else to
say?
Michael: Sorry, go ahead.
Bobby: Yeah, so maybe we should finish up
the Nietzsche thing and then I should get
into some slides and then we should come
back to this.
Brendan: Yeah, I was just going to say
real quick again, I think bobby, I think
what you're articulating, I.
Mean, having read your book and talked
with you a lot about your work, I think
we're very much on the same page.
I was very much also at the same time
doing a devil's advocate thing, though,
for a couple of reasons, and it would
derail us too much from the present topic,
, which is more important than trying to
make a devil's advocate case for living
with determinism.
Bobby: Yeah, well, I told Daniel that I'm
a recovering determinist.
That's kind of what I want to do here,
because I said if we don't hear the
criticism, then the people who don't
agree with this, I'm not going to answer.
.
So I'm glad you said that, but I would
just like to push you a little bit more
to explain.
If it's purely deterministic, where's the
responsibility that Nietzsche is talking
about?
Brendan: Yeah, well, let me say maybe a
couple of things too that adds further
context here.
There's sort of a tradition of, let's say
using historical, philosophical or even
theological categories and the kind of
frameworks that those used to provide for
making sense of really important concepts
and ways of being in the world and then
presuming that if someone deviated from
those that there would be these natural,
necessary sort of implications that would
flow from thinking differently about
something.
The classic case in my experience has
been, oh, we need morality and moral
facts to make us good people.
As soon as you don't believe in moral
facts, you'll become a terrible human
being.
And that's not true.
People who don't believe in moral facts
in the kind of traditional way can find
all sorts of groundings for their.
Bobby: Moral yeah, sorry to interrupt,
but I can see these language things going
on everywhere in these discussions.
So, for example yeah, so you're saying
that people don't need morality and that
these people but then you said
traditional morality.
So that was the point I was going to make,
, is that the people who let's say you
don't believe that there's any
purposefulness in nature, there's no
teleology, everything's random and
accidental.
Then they go, well, you know what?
That doesn't make me depressed.
This is the only time, this is all we've
got, so I better make it count.
There's no afterlife.
So what I'm saying is they're still
deriving morals from this paradigm and
they're actually deriving meaning and
purposeful principles out of this.
So they're really, in a way, they're
still finding what they need to find to
behave in an optimal way.
But what I'm saying is that that's kind
of a teleological view and they're not
fully sticking to their paradigm with no
assumptions.
They're building on lots of assumptions.
And you get this morality that ends up
looking exactly like religion once you
map it out and you go, oh yeah, like the
Golden Rule, for example.
The golden rule.
You don't need a religion or the Golden
Rule.
You just need to know that you're an
agent there are other agents like you,
they're like you, they also experience
happiness and suffering.
Therefore I'm going to treat them like I
would want to be treated.
And also there's an incentive to do that
because then they can treat me that way,
then they'll treat me as I've treated
them.
But the golden rule could be a basis for
a religion and a moral postulate.
So are they really morally free of moral
facts or are they creating a set of
morals from a paradigm that's supposed to
be completely moral free?
Maybe it's not because what I'm saying
basically is they're kind of converging
on this kind of purposeful narrative
without even realizing it.
Brendan: Well yeah, there's a lot there.
I mean I would say what you're getting at,
, which is important, which is there is
often a performative contradiction that
we're engaged in, we're asserting
something logically and then our actions
are sort of suggesting otherwise.
I mean if I'm a solipsist and I say I
believe in solipsism and I think this is
sort of like well wait, why are you
telling me that?
So there's that element to it.
There are actually though some rather
detailed arguments you could make that
get into things like well yes, I'm a
solipsist but I'm talking to you about it
because you're a projection of me and it'
's still worthwhile for me to have
projections with conversational,
projections with myself, et cetera.
And there are versions of that for the
free will sort of a thing.
Bobby: But I think there's fallacies with
all of that.
So for example, let's say there's old
joke about the teacher gives a lecture on
solipsism and why solipsism can't be
refuted and the student comes up to him
after the lecture and says oh you're a
solipsist too, like he's happy to meet
another solipsist but the whole point is
that the other person doesn't exist.
So you're happy to meet yourself.
What I would say is let's follow that
anytime.
Okay, so then we would do a little game
where we break that down.
And what I'm saying when you start to
break all those things down they lead you
back to the same road.
So let's say you're not real Brendan, you'
're a projection of my mind.
But what does that mean?
Brendan is a projection of my mind but
you're an agent and you have different
beliefs than me as I know myself here.
And you're going to do things, you're
going to behave in ways that are
different than I would behave because you
have a different set of beliefs
ultimately compared to actually the me I
know, even if you're really me.
What I'm saying is that really me doesn't
really have any meaning.
Because when you start to define you as
this agent, even if you make this
metaphysical claim that you're a
projection of me, for all practical
purposes, you are an agent within this
system that has a different set of
beliefs than what I know that behaves
differently.
So what I'm saying is even the thought
experiment has this language fall because
you come back to the equivalence of it's
not really a meaningful statement to say
whether it's me or not.
If it has all these properties, that
counts as an individual agent in the
reality that we can be aware of, if that
makes sense.
Brendan: Yeah, and I agree.
If we really followed this through, I
think we would converge to the same point,
, which for me tends to be well, I'll
frame this a little bit by saying
something like, hume, you're just
mentioning earlier about how Sam Harris
said, I wouldn't tell it to my daughter.
Hume skeptic would question will the sun
actually rise?
Et cetera.
But he made the point that basically once
he puts his philosopher pen down and he
goes and leaves his study, he's now
living like a regular person now, you
could say.
So there's a potentially meaningful
distinction between the pragmatism and
the sort of intellectual logical
coherence, let's say.
But I do think that there's a meaningful
way that we can actually collapse those
in a way that should be collapsed because
it would lead to something like what
information about reality has causal
power for sustaining my viability and
flourishing in the face of entropy.
Right.
Kind of tie back in some of this free
energy principle Bayesian updating sort
of thing here.
Right.
And this is the point that you introduced
me about the work of, like, Kolchinsky
and Walpert, which I've made great use of,
, of thinking about meaningful
information as being that meaning that a
system produces by processing information
about its environment that ultimately
AIDS its viability.
Right.
Now, if what we're talking about in a
pragmatic sense has a deleterious effect
on our viability because of our concepts,
then we might say that that actually is
decreasing our viability.
And therefore, we might be inclined to
say if that's our sort of criterion for
asserting information as being an
accurate model of reality, which I'm not
sure of a better one, then we could say
that things like skepticism and solipsism
are untrue on that ground.
If that line makes any sense, you could
really start to unpack that.
But I think that that might be where we'd
ultimately converge.
In agreement on some of these points?
On some of these points.
Bobby: Yeah.
Adam: I'm going to have to run in 5
minutes, unfortunately.
So I'll just throw in a couple of quick
thoughts.
Bobby: Oh, let me just say one sentence
before I forget.
Maybe I already forgot.
Let's see.
Okay.
Go ahead, Adam.
I'll try to remember it.
Adam: Sorry.
Bobby: That's okay.
Sorry.
Yeah.
When you were talking about viability,
like all these explanations, like, oh,
well, maybe I don't have free will, but
being optimistic has some positive effect.
.
What I'm trying to say is if the micro
scale determinism is true and we're going
to break that's one point I want to make
determinism.
When people are saying that word, it's
conflating two different things.
There's physical determinism that I'm
talking about, like micro determinism,
where everything is just this model, like
where you have these atoms are basically
pool balls and they're following these
trajectories.
I'll get to that in a slide.
But that's a different kind of
determinism than saying that your genes
and experiences give rise to what you do.
.
My point is, if you're saying all these
if the microscale determinism is true,
there's no need to even talk about, oh,
optimism helps me.
There's no like, oh, even being
optimistic.
All of that biological level talk is
causally redundant.
So basically, if there's microscale
determinism, genes even aren't
determining anything that's causal over
determinism.
You're saying, okay, the genes cause my
behavior, but then you said the atoms
cause my behavior.
So my point is, if microscale determinism
is true, you don't even have genes
determining your behavior.
It's an incoherent argument.
And Sam Harris is conflating these two
types of determinism and flipping back
and forth.
So what I'm saying is we got to break
this down.
And what agency, what top down causation
does is it overcomes this physical
determinism and then there's biological
determinism that determines what agents
will do.
And I'm saying that consciousness and
self awareness, reflective thought is
what overrides biological determinism.
And that's when basically your higher
mind, like this monitoring kind of
prefrontal cortex executive control, like
the mind that's responsible for that,
there's access consciousness versus
phenomenal consciousness distinction.
So that mind can override your biological
programming, your impulsive actions.
So when we have this hierarchical model,
we see that there's two types of
determinism at least, and then there's
multiple types of top down causation
which overcome those things.
So not to say that that argument doesn't
hold up.
Like we have to talk about determinism as
far as genes determining your behavior.
But my point is, if someone believes in
microscale determinism, then these higher
level things, when people say, oh, your
genes are deciding what you're doing,
those things would also be epiphenomenal.
.
Those would be shorthands because you
could actually look at the genes and you
could see a bunch of particles and then
you could use Newtonian trajectories just
applied to the particles.
The genes are epiphenomenal.
Now the neurons are epiphenomenal.
So it's a level of new I don't know, adam,
, have you thought about that at all?
Adam: Yeah.
And that's kind of part of my agnosticism
is like, is there such a thing as a true
atomism?
Does causation even make sense if it's
just like an undifferentiated quantum
field?
For instance, as soon as we're talking
about particles or kinds of anything we
can even name or pick out, are we
basically core screening?
And are we in kind of like when we say
micro, why don't we just keep going?
Isn't it already somewhat like an
instrumental for a given purpose?
But in terms of and I've kind of kept
these separate, like these issues of the
philosophy of causation, like the
handlings of free will.
So I've tended to focus on functional
cybernetic free will, basically the
planning and the architecture of choice
and being able to suss out different
options and evaluate counterfactuals that
you then have different control energy
for the system.
But I think there could be really
interesting connections between how we
handle causation, though, and where
within the control hierarchy and the way
you're describing of what's responsible
for what.
So, like ways in which system two can
override system one or like that's.
Bobby: Absolutely what I want to develop
here because I think you can bridge this
low level Causation discussion that I'm
talking about, which, for example, Paul
davies and sarah walker have written
about informational control and that's
with the origin of life, there's this
change in the causal structure of the
system, and then it gains this agency.
And that's what I focused on a lot in
part one of the book.
And so what I'm saying is Adam's work
focuses on basically this free will topic,
, where I'm saying that there's this even
higher level system beyond just normal
biological agents that comes with not
just consciousness, but an ability to
create counterfactuals and imagination.
So it's like prefrontal cortex sort of
higher self.
And a lot of people say the self
solutionary.
That's why I love to fall back on Adam's
work, because it really breaks down the
self from a mechanistic perspective.
But that's exactly what we can do.
We can look at the space of
counterfactuals.
And as we will see that, I think there is
some indeterminism at the fundamental
level of reality that propagates up.
And that's what you see with chaos, even
though it's called deterministic chaos.
And that's a whole nother issue to get
into.
But basically I'm saying that there are
choices and that the world's trajectory
is not set in stone and there's some
variation.
And when we as agents consider the space
of counterfactuals and then choose
something specifically, it may be
something like we're going to make a
choice.
And then our biases, like our impulsive
decision, is to make a certain choice
reflexively based on how we feel and our
genetic programming and our experiences.
But then we can have another process
where we go, okay, is this decision
optimal?
Given my principles, I have this higher
self now.
I think about what's good, what I want to
do, what are my long term goals, and that
is the mechanism that corresponds to what
people mean when they talk about free
will.
And so I'm excited about that in working
with Adam to explain that to people who
just think that there's no way free will
can work, because he's talked about these
mechanisms from this cybernetic and
computational neuroscience perspective
and formalized them.
People like Sabina Hawsenfelder, like
physicists, are like saying there's no
way free will can be compatible with a
causal picture of the world.
I don't think that's true, but what I
wanted and Adam's going to leave, so he's
unfortunately not going to be part of
this, but he'll see it later.
I think we can bridge Adam's work at this
higher level to this low level causation
stuff to actually have a causal story
where there's actually still cause and
effect, but there's higher level
causation that can basically override the
sort of the lower level bottom up
causation.
And then you even get these higher levels
where you can have that sort of causation
being overridden by conscious, like
mental causation.
So you would have bottom up causation and
then top down causation and then mental
causation and top down and mental
causation.
They would all be looped under,
categorized under downward causation.
Or you could call them all top down
causation.
But there are differences when
consciousness emerges that allows for
what could be called new causal power.
Things are working in a similar way, but
you will see a behavioral change when you
get consciousness that will allow for
things like technology, things that
require imagination, counterfactual
generation, that can't be achieved with
lower level intelligence, and that we can
actually construct a causal picture that
is perfectly in line with everything we
know about causality.
But when you do this, you realize that
the bottom up story and I haven't really
defined that.
You guys know what I'm talking about, but
I haven't defined it for the listeners.
But that when you have this story of
causation, you have agents emerge and
they're actually control centers that can
initiate causal chains.
And they do it for reasons.
There's always reasons that you want to
make a certain decision over another.
So some people think because you have a
reason, that's a cause, that somehow that'
's not free will.
But if you didn't have a reason for it,
you would be doing it randomly and that
wouldn't be free will either.
So free will just has to be
reconceptualized within this framework.
And it's not full free will, but full
free will wouldn't be free will in the
first place because again, it would be
random if it was not based on a reason.
But what I'm saying is that your reason,
even though it's a cause, the reasons, it'
's not determined, because basically it's
not determined in the same sense that
people are talking about with physical
determinism.
We'll get to this.
There's no way I can do it without
looking at the slides.
But if anyone has any comments about what
I just said and Adam, I know you got to
go.
So any final concluding thoughts?
Adam: I am furious that I have to go, but
I'm looking forward to tuning in in a bit.
.
So talk to you soon.
Bobby: See adam, thanks for coming.
Michael: May I interject for a second?
Bobby: Yeah.
If anybody wants to read Adam's papers on
integrated world modeling theory and
cybernetic free will, you can just Google
his name in those terms, and you'll see
some great papers and some really
respected journals like Entropy, I think,
is the integrated world modeling three
one.
Yeah, Michael.
Michael: No, I'm just trying to, again,
do my job here or whatever.
But Daniel, I did want to ask your
thoughts about active inference at this
juncture.
Bobby: Yeah, any thoughts about active
inference, how that applies to anything
we've said already.
And I will link it to that soon because I
know a lot of listeners that's what they'
're interested in.
Daniel: I'll definitely look forward to
how you link it.
But although active inference is this
incredible modern, composable framework
for, on one hand, cognitive modeling and
on the other hand, the actual embodied
situational modeling, a lot of the reason
why people get into it, get curious,
start participating in the institute, is
exactly the topic of self help and self
improvement and personal decision making
amidst multiscale uncertainty.
And so there's among the many gaps
between theory and application or
practice, one of them is utilizing these
kinds of multiscale information geometry,
decision making, moment of choice type
frameworks for what for what we actually
do.
So this is something that really strikes
at the heart of what we do, as infra ants.
.
And I'm just looking forward to how you
frame it in this narrative and then we
can come back to some more technical
details, too.
Bobby: Yeah, so we're going to cap it at
eight, I guess, at 750.
I don't know if you'll have many
questions in the chat, but I'm going to
try to give the presentation in the next
45 minutes.
But feel free to comment on stuff that
will still be helpful.
But I guess we shouldn't get too far into,
, like, make a comment so we can mark it.
.
I might give a little answer and then we'
'll come back to it.
But I prefer that you speak up because
then we'll know what to come back to.
So I'll say a few more things about
causality because they're important, and
then I'll get into kind of the bigger
picture of the theory and then
specifically the self help teleological
stance, which is the free energy
principle comes into play there.
And yeah, then we can talk about
practical applications for the individual
and first society.
Because the goal is that this system can
be used it's kind of like a theory of
everything.
So it explains reality, but that it can
be used to improve your life as an
individual, but also be used to figure
out how to sort of optimize our social
systems, political systems.
So it kind of creates a logic that could
be used to base a new political party on,
like, a third party or something, which
would be great if we had a party kind of
based on systems thinking.
We kind of need a bipartisan ideology
right now that's not based on anything
other than evidence based things that we
know can be used to optimize systems, not
that that's everything.
But what I'm saying is it provides a
foundation that then the ethical and kind
of moral stances emerge from.
And if you don't see this basic cosmic
story, then you will be confused about
ethical issues.
And what I will argue is that folk
psychology, ethics, all of that stuff I
believe is consistent with this view
because it was kind of intuitive that
this is the story of nature and that it
will kind of ease that cognitive
dissonance for people who have accepted
the reductionist view.
I know a lot of people have accepted this
view that there's no agency, that there's
just the strict determinism, but then
they want to use this free energy
principle type things to improve their
life.
But that's kind of a contradiction
because are they choosing to improve it
or is there just one trajectory that's
set in stone?
I think that getting this stuff straight
will allow people to embrace stuff like
the free energy principle and apply it to
their lives because they go, okay, I can
actually use this and I can do that, and
I can create change in myself and in the
society I'm a part of.
But with this old model, there's no hope
for change because there's only one
trajectory.
And so if Nietzsche really took that
seriously, it would be no reason to
really talk about responsibility because
it's just purely a block time frozen
thing where the future is already
determined from the initial state.
And the fact that it would repeat over
and over is just even more hell.
Determinism was bad enough.
Now you have to experience not having an
illusion forever.
So what I want to offer is a different
model that we can't fully get into but
what I have called eternal recursive
emergence.
And so that it's not a cyclical process.
It's actually a process of the universe
evolving and maybe giving rise to
something new, potentially like a new
universe.
There's cosmological natural selection.
We don't have to go there.
We don't have to talk about anything
outside of this universe.
But my point is that yeah, so what I want
to show is that the universe is not an
arbitrary system.
It's not random.
It is a system that exhibits a design.
You can say it's the appearance of a
design.
Maybe it's not really design, but there's
qualities that can't be explained.
If the universe was the only universe in
all of reality, you couldn't have that
theory.
Either there's a designer that designed
it that way, or there's a larger reality
with a multiverse that would explain this
fine tuning.
And that's where basically science went.
They said, okay, it looks like there's a
creator because of the fine tuning
problem, but we can't accept that.
So we have to consider this multiverse
option.
But the multiverse option is just as
weird as a creator.
It leads to all kinds of crazy things
like other universes, where there's every
possible version of you.
So it probably has just as much baggage
as the creator thing.
But then there's cosmological natural
selection, which basically is an
evolutionary explanation where basically
universes give rise to other universes.
And there's this Darwinian selection
principle that would lead to a universe
optimized for complexity, growth, and
life essentially spreading continuously.
So we don't really need to get in those
metaphysical topics.
But I just wanted to state up front that
the universe does have something that we
could call a design.
But when I say that, don't assume that I
am talking about it being created by some
sort of conscious intelligent agent.
It could be this evolutionary process,
but it's not random, it's not arbitrary.
And that's the big mistake, is that we
have models of a random system, like a
gas.
That's what Boltzman used to kind of try
to have a statistical foundation of the
second law of thermodynamics.
And the problem is, we based the dynamics
of that inanimate system.
I mean, we understood the dynamics of
that inanimate system, and then we
assumed that the universe behaved the
same way, and that led to all of these
bad assumptions that created this
nihilistic worldview.
So let me talk about that first.
If determinism is true, like if there
were no indeterminism at the lowest level,
, for example, everything was just made
of these atoms.
And these atoms were like classical scale
objects, like pool balls on a pool table.
.
And you have all these atoms.
And if those atoms follow classical
trajectories and they're just like
basically you can imagine the universe as
a table of pool balls, then there's no
room for anything.
There's one future trajectory, and it's
set in stone.
So if you believe that, if you accept
that worldview, there is no other future,
there's no changing it.
And if you believe that and you want to
change your life and you're really taking
this seriously, you would have to ask
yourself, well, if I change my life, am I
really changing it?
Or was this the way it was always
supposed to happen?
It was determined that I was going to
change my life?
Or are you saying, like, it's determined
in a way where you can't change your life,
, so you shouldn't even try?
It leads to all these weird conclusions.
But what I'm saying is that's not the way
reality is.
And that leads to this worldview where
you have no agency.
You can't get around it because if it's a
purely pool ball universe, then there's
no agency.
Not only that, so that's the first thing.
.
If the world was Newtonian at the micro
level, there would be no agency.
There would be one trajectory, and there
would be this block time thing.
Everything would follow from the initial
state in a way that was calculable from
just specifying the positions of every
particle and applying Newton's laws to
those.
And then we have some forces that
interact, but it doesn't really change
the picture.
So there's just one continual trajectory.
.
Then Boltzman found that an inanimate
system because all of in a gas, for
example.
So it's a specific type of system that
Boltzman was using to derive the second
law of thermodynamics on a statistical
foundation.
And it's not the way open systems work.
So first of all, we should know that he
showed with statistical mechanics that if
you have a gas so in a gas, every
particle is uncorrelated, it's just
moving around freely.
And in his model also, people should know
that this is before we understood the
periodic table.
Periodic table didn't come till like
decades after Boltzman did this work.
So we didn't understand like chemical
bonding, for example.
We didn't understand a lot of things.
So in his model, as an idealization, used
spherical, like what would be marbles,
like spherical round things that bump off
each other elastically.
So they just bounce off each other.
They don't combine and interact with
forces.
And if you have this picture, if you have
these things just bumping off of each
other, interacting this way, moving
around, following these classical
trajectories, not bound in any way, you
will get a transition from order to
disorder if the system starts out in an
ordered state, of course, because the
disordered state, there's more possible
ways to do that.
So if everything's moving around randomly,
, you see this trajectory here that we
see and then so the idea but there were
so many weird assumptions in trying to
apply this to our universe.
Like when you start to break them down,
none of them really made sense.
So he was saying, okay, this is what has
to happen.
You go from order to disorder and this
must be the way the universe is, because
this is what has to happen by statistical
laws.
If everything's moving randomly, if there'
's no magical forces doing thing, this is
what happens.
So the problem with that basically well,
so one thing I should say is that's not
even true.
If this was the way the world is, and
people pointed this out to Boltzman,
given enough time, if these are following
these mechanical trajectories, even the
disordered state will go back to the
ordered state given enough time.
This is Coincare's recurrence theorem,
kind of similar to Nietzsche's eternal
recurrence.
But so the idea is that if you have the
system behaving this way, basically all
trajectories are possible and given
enough time, it will go from disorder.
And then we'll revert.
And people challenged Boltsman with this
and he couldn't get away from that
possibility.
I lost my train of thought earlier.
I didn't let you know, I just went on to
the next thing.
But what I forgot to say was that
Boltzman was like faced with the problem
of why is our universe look so complex if
it goes from order to disorder?
And then that's where so he had to say,
oh, well, it must have.
Started out really ordered because it can'
't go from disorder to order.
So it must have been this highly ordered
state, which was the beginning of time.
It was this low, low entropy state.
But now we know that after the Big Bang,
everything was homogeneous, and then
things started aggregating.
So it was literally an equilibrium state,
this fully mixed up high disorder state,
something closer to that before that.
And then things started plumping and you
get more organization.
So the story is completely the opposite
of what we've been taught.
Julian Barber, in his new book, explains
this, that the trajectory of the universe
is towards higher complexity and order,
and that we made a mistake by applying
this model of an inanimate system to the
universe in its entirety.
When the universe has all of these
batteries in the sky, we call stars, and
they're driving systems away from
equilibrium.
So then we had Elia Prigogene in 19 40,
19 50, 19 60, 19 70.
I would say fifty S and sixty S were
probably when he was starting this work,
and it was really gaining influence.
But he basically showed that there's
another dynamic where if you have a
system of particles driven by a flow of
energy, it will start to naturally
organize that system, assuming that the
molecules combine to each other.
So you need to have the right sort of
molecular variety for this to happen.
But this model of boltzman's didn't take
into account bonding.
It didn't take into account the force of
gravity, it didn't take account into
account open systems.
And what I'm arguing is ultimately that
the universe's dynamics are more like an
open system being pushed far from
equilibrium, where it's self organizing.
So in this model, the universe isn't
going towards disorder because it's not a
universe made of particles that stay
uncorrelated.
So this Bolton's model was based on this
H theorem, where everything stays
uncorrelated, but when things interact,
they become correlated.
So this model works for gases and it
doesn't work for open systems.
And what I'm saying is, it doesn't work
for the universe.
We applied it to the universe.
And if this was true, there's only one
trajectory, which means there's no
changing the future.
What's going to happen is going to happen.
.
And if that's the case, that's pretty
depressing because it kind of demotivates
us to go, oh, you know what?
I can change the world.
I can have this idea, and it can blow up
like Mark Zuckerberg, like creating
Facebook.
Like, you could create something like
Facebook, and you would have that and you
would change the world.
But if you believed in determinism, it
would be kind of strange.
You would be like, wait, but this is
already determined.
So I already did it.
In a way, I'm already going to do it, and
there's only one trajectory, and then I
play that important role in history.
No, that can't be true.
This is impossible.
I'm going to change the world and it was
determined.
So that philosophy leads to a lot of
weirdness that I'm saying completely
dissipates when we get the causal picture
straight and we see that there's not this
nihilistic one trajectory because of
quantum indeterminism and that's not
everything.
But what quantum indeterminism does is it
shows that when you shrink when you zoom
in and you get to a certain level that
Newton's laws of motion do not hold you
will see there will be no definite state
of an electron that you can predict given
its prior state.
There's only going to be a wave function
that gives a distribution of
probabilities where that can go and then
use the Born rule to find out where it's
likely to go.
And then if you repeat that study a bunch
of times you'll see these statistical
patterns.
So what I'm saying is quantum and
determinism got rid of this picture of
strict determinism at the micro level.
And if you did have that strict
determinism at the micro level you would
not have any agency or any there would be
no real counterfactuals.
They would be sort of due to our
epistemic limitations what we can know
about the world.
We think there are different
possibilities but there actually are none.
.
The world can only go one way.
And what I'm saying is that there are
some different there's a possibility
space of things that can happen and that
when agents make decisions.
You're carving out a path that in some
ways it's not determined by the
microscale physics because of quantum
indeterminism.
And then we have chaos, too at the
classical scale where you can't predict
what a chaotic system is going to do.
People call it deterministic chaos.
I have issues with calling that
determinism because it's completely not
predictable and I don't even think
determinism is the right word.
People want to look up norton's dome.
If you have a ball posed at the top of
the dome there's multiple Newton's
equations that can satisfy where it's
going to go next.
There's actually even determinism is not
fully deterministic.
But that's kind of beyond what we'll get
into.
Let me just try to go faster through the
slide since it's 720.
So I'm not going to talk about a lot of
the details that I planned but maybe our
earlier conversation provides context
that can clear all this stuff up.
So what I'm arguing is that the universe
is self organizing.
And so Lee Smollen, popular physicist
says the possibility of conceiving the
universe as a whole as a self organized
system in which a variety of improbable
structures exist permanently without the
need of a pilot or other external agent I
can't see that word.
So we have the possibility of
constructing a new scientific cosmology.
It's clear that if the natural state of
matter is chaos and external intelligence
isn't needed to explain the order and
beauty of the world so he's basically
saying if we had this model of randomness,
, then it wouldn't make sense for us to
see what we see.
And we would need a creator would be a
better explanation.
But if life order and structure are the
natural state of the cosmos itself, then
our existence, indeed our spirit, might
finally be comprehended and as created
naturally by the world rather than
unnaturally and in opposition to it.
And you'll see up here that he says, a
variety of improbable structures that
exist permanently.
So what I'm saying is there's some
language issues here that we're seeing,
where we're saying, why do we see all
this improbable stuff if it's there?
It's not improbable.
So it's only improbable if we accept the
old model based on this simplified model
of causation that doesn't include top
down causation, which we'll explain.
And that actually complexity that you
would say that this is highly improbable,
that complexity just keeps growing and
growing and growing, because
statistically you would think that there
would be some transient complexity, and
then basically you would have this trend
towards entropy, that this complexity
would dissolve.
What I'm saying is when I'm saying that
the universe is becoming more and more
complex, it's not opposed to naturalism.
It's that our conception of naturalism is
based on an outdated paradigm that did
not include dynamics that really exist,
that we're now just finding so that these
structures that are highly complex were
never improbable.
And I'm actually going to argue that they'
're statistically inevitable, that they
arise in a way deterministically.
And it might be kind of confusing that I
use that word.
But what I'm going to try to argue is
that when we talk about determinism, we
need to make distinctions between that as
well.
So what I'm saying is that there's strict
determinism is not true.
But I'm now going to argue that something
like global determinism is true, which is
a name that's been used by philosophers,
that there are attractors that create
these dynamics such that it is natural
that the world goes towards increasing
complexity and that if we see this
trajectory that we're a part of, life is
spreading.
We're building technology.
The biosphere has created all this
complexity on Earth.
If we spread we're spreading complexity
throughout the universe in the form of
computational structures.
Life is a computational structure.
This information processing network that
we call the biosphere is spreading.
If life spreads that that was never
improbable.
It was just improbable because it seemed
improbable, because we didn't have all of
the laws.
And that actually it's inevitable, but
that there is some freedom within that,
but there is an outline that's basically
deterministic at this larger scale.
And by that I mean things can go a
different way.
Like if you rewound the tape of time and
you played it again, that different
events, there would be a slightly
different chain of events that would
happen.
You would get different, for example,
genetic mutations, because genetic
mutation and Schrodinger was the first
person to speculate about this, but that
there's a quantum component.
So if you rewound the tape of time and
you played it again, you would get some
different genes.
But what I'm arguing is, because of these
emergent attractor dynamics that were
really explained by non equilibrium
physics and the work of Ilioprikajin,
then what you see is that you would get
the same trajectory towards higher and
higher complexity because there were
other laws that we weren't aware of.
And so in this model, there's going to be
a sort of cosmic destiny that is this
sort of form of global determinism.
And then there's going to be free agency
that the agents can do things that's not
set in stone within that kind of global
deterministic picture.
So it's kind of new.
I'm saying that it's not binaries the
world deterministic or indeterministic.
There's indeterminism at the lowest level,
, which basically introduces slack into
the causal chain.
So not everything is fully determined in
the strict sense.
But because of these attractors, you get
these emergent dynamics where you're
going to see similar patterns, similar
regularities.
So Christoph Coke just a couple
scientists who well, yeah, I'll skip this
stuff, but so there are a lot of
scientists who a lot of philosophers who
have had this kind of teleological
narrative that the universe was moving
towards some sort of goal, that it seemed
to be like an organism that's developing
and that seemed like an idea opposed to
naturalism.
People like Tilharde, Chardin and Bergson
were Chardin was religious, but Bergson
was a philosopher.
That wasn't really.
So I think a lot of these people got
criticized wrongly.
They were actually seeing what was right
about nature.
But this view was thought to be opposed
to naturalism.
That was teleological and that had to be
some sort of mystical force.
And what I'm saying is we just didn't
know about certain things.
We didn't understand information and that
these people were right and that a lot of
people will hear this and say, oh, well,
that's against science.
They might think it's against the second
law of thermodynamics or something.
But no, there's a big misunderstanding
about that.
And all of these people are all the
scientists on this page.
Really, everyone with the exception of a
couple of the phosphorus, are extremely
respected and very accomplished people
who support this view.
I mean, Ray Kurzwald, his technology guy,
is a little bit more out there, but he
even uses the word destiny.
Destiny.
It is clear that the physical laws of our
universe are precisely what they need to
be to allow for the evolution of
increasing levels of order and complexity.
.
Ultimately, the entire universe will
become saturated with intelligence.
This is the destiny of the universe.
So what I'm saying is that this is the
trajectory of cosmic evolution.
This is the roadmap of the future.
And this provides something like an
outline for non reductionist theory of
everything based on emergence.
So you have, first physics and chemistry
emerge, then biology, then brains, then
technology, and then the merger of
biology with technology.
And then you get patterns of matter and
energy, and the Universe becomes
saturated with intelligent processes and
knowledge.
So life expands.
And we do that because we have to.
We're going to run out of energy on this
planet.
Our star is going to die, which
necessitates that we move outward, and
then we extract the energy from that, and
we keep moving outward.
And as we do, the informational network
that is life keeps expanding, and it
keeps taking inanimate matter in the
world and incorporating that into its
computational substrate.
So the island of agency, the island of
information keeps spreading and subsuming
the inanimate world.
And I'm saying that that is an inevitable
process.
And people say, well, that seems very
unlikely.
And if that's happening, then it's not
part of the design or it's not part of
the code of the universe.
Like, it's not necessitated by the
parameters, the laws and the constants.
They'll say it's just something that
could have happened, and it's unlikely,
but we're defying the odds.
Now, when those people say that they don'
't even realize their own ontology, like,
if they believe in determinism, then
there's only one trajectory, there's only
one thing that could happen.
So there's no likely or not likely.
If you really believe in determinism,
there's no statistics, and there's really
no causation.
It's just one thing follows another.
And people have talked about that.
If determinism is true, then even
causality is an illusion.
It's just one sort of fabric of events
that all follow from the initial event.
So what I'm arguing is that the universe
shows the dynamics of a far from
equilibrium system, a driven system, and
that it moving towards complexity isn't
violating any laws, and it's not
improbable.
We just didn't understand far from
equilibrium dynamics and that the
universe's complexity doesn't have to be
transient.
So Sean Carroll has this thing where he's
showing, like, the increase in complexity
and the increase in entropy, and people
go, okay, this is making sense.
Complexity is not opposed to entropy.
It's part of that.
But it goes up and then it goes down.
You have the coffee, and you have the
cream and the coffee mixing, and you get
this complexity, and then it all becomes
homogeneous.
What I'm saying is, no, that's not true
for the universe at all.
Complexity keeps going because when life
emerges, it's not like some complexity.
Like, you get some random pebbles
arranged as a crystal, and then the wind
blows and then they disperse.
Life is robust.
It's modeled the world.
And because it's modeled the world, it
can maintain its own existence.
So, for example, if an asteroid is coming
at the Earth in 100 years, assuming that
we advance technologically at the rate we'
've been, we're going to destroy that
asteroid.
We're going to do what we need to do to
preserve life.
And that's going to change the
deterministic trajectory of the inanimate
world.
So life changes the trajectory of the
inanimate world.
But what I'm saying, it was inevitable
that life emerges and does this.
So there is a sort of trajectory that's
sort of set in stone from the initial
parameters, but that this trajectory is
the opposite trajectory of what Boltzman
thought.
It's actually towards greater and greater
organization and the discussion of where'
's the limit?
If this universe wakes up and the whole
thing becomes this integrated
computational system, when does it have
to stop?
What about the second law of
thermodynamics?
What about the energy needs?
And I wrote an article for NOAMA called
Life Need Not Ever End.
And it was shared by David Deutsch and
Sabine Hawson felder and Robin Hansen
also were commenting on it and saying,
yes, it's possible that life could
potentially not have a limit.
It depends on if there's an upper bound
to entropy.
Robin Hansen said Sabine was like, I have
a chapter on this in my book.
So a lot of the things that we took as
gospel, like the First Law and Second Law
of thermodynamics, those apply very well
to certain systems, but we shouldn't have
applied them to the Universe as a whole.
The first law of thermodynamics is just
like there's conservation of energy which
holds, and we use that to calculate
things, but the statement matter can't be
created or destroyed.
Absolutely not true.
Cosmic inflation theory has new matter
and energy created during the cosmic
inflation period continuously.
And then now with the expansion of the
Universe, there's dark energy constantly
being created as well.
There's this astronomy conference paper
where people have speculated, have argued
that we can use dark energy, and that's
getting more speculative to continue to
power life.
We might not even need that.
If you read my article, you'll see this,
but you can look up on Sean Carroll's
blog.
He has an article called Energy is not
conserved.
And it talks about basically the First
Law is not true in the way some people
thought it was.
I didn't mean to do that.
Let me go back to this slide.
So let's speed it up.
So maybe this is where we're at now.
So it's a series of these stages.
And what I'm saying is we're at this
stage, and that the biosphere mirrors a
brain.
It's an information network of agents
exchanging information through the
Internet and that there's actually people.
.
I say that's cosmic mysticism.
Well, there's some interesting new
theories by people like Lee Smallen and
John Lanier arguing that the Universe is
a learning machine and everything in that
paper is consistent with this view.
So go read that paper.
Read the universe's neural network by
vitali.
He has a group on Facebook, and we've
been meeting.
We're taking a break for the summer and
making some videos.
But basically there's a mathematical
foundation for this picture.
And so calling it cosmic mysticism is
just not true anymore.
And you can have a fundamentally
purposeful universe headed towards this,
what TLR de Chardin would describe as
like an omega point.
And it's completely consistent with
naturalism, as long as you update
naturalism to include these new dynamics.
.
So I was going to talk about phase
transitions.
So basically, these stages in cosmic
evolution occur from components like
nature's fundamental particles combining
to make higher level systems.
So we have atoms come together to form
molecules, which come together to form
cells, which come together to form
organisms and ecosystems.
And then the biosphere is this fully
integrated network.
So those are phase transitions.
It occurs in stages.
We have a depiction here.
We see a single celled organism.
And then those organisms, you can think
of a slime mold.
So you have a bunch of, like, paramesium
or something, and then they need to solve
a problem.
And so they come together and they solve
They form multicellular organism.
So here's a slime molding, here's a human.
.
And these agents also come together to
form larger collectives.
And every time you have one of these, it'
's called a phase transition.
And it's exactly the same as the phase
transitions.
Not exactly the same, but the same
category of phenomena.
Like when you have water freeze into ice.
.
But we have these non equilibrium phase
transitions where you'll have, like, the
emergence of a tornado or a whirlpool in
your bathtub and basically these little
units, like in the formation of a
Whirlpool, you have all these atoms that
are bouncing around chaotically.
And due to some thermodynamic constraints
that we won't get into here, they start
to organize themselves into these
collective formations that create these
flow patterns.
And you can see these organized
structures.
And that life is basically another
version of this.
And that when atoms come together to make
our subatomic particles come together to
make an atom.
Like these phase transitions, they
continue in the hierarchy of life.
So you have agents coming together,
single cellulants to make multicellular,
then to make societies.
And these phase transitions happen at
this edge of chaos.
So there's this sort of dialectical
dynamic between order and chaos that
creates complexity.
And really, everything is going through
these cycles.
So when there's a phase transition, you
don't want a system to be too stable
because it's too rigid to transition to
the next stage.
So there will be periods of chaos like we'
're experiencing right now in society.
And you might think that the world's
ending, but it's actually an indication
that a phase transition is about to
happen.
And so the system has the potential to
either collapse or to transition into a
higher state of organization.
And so this shows these different stages.
.
You have nonliving, then you have it with
living.
You go from cells to military organisms
to tribes and cities, nations and into
gaia.
And then it can even extend from like
when we TerraForm Mars, that's the
biosphere self replicating.
And so life will basically the spread of
life is like this higher level unit that'
's the biosphere making copies of itself
with variation and selection.
And then life would potentially, I'm
arguing, inevitably subsume solar systems
and galaxies and so on.
So let's skip some stuff and get into the
self help stuff, since we don't have much
time.
Daniel, do we have to cut it eight or can
we go 10 minutes longer?
Daniel: We can go 10 minutes over.
Bobby: We'll only go ten.
I don't want to keep you too long, but
that will help with the questions.
If I can end at eight, then we can do 10
minutes.
If questions are maybe I'll try to end
before.
So these phase transitions create these
memory systems, so these higher organized
systems like life.
So when we get the first cell, we have
genetic memory, and that's encoding
information that the organism basically
that living things have discovered
through evolution.
So evolution is this process where it's
making these different copies of these
organisms.
So there's a genome with some information,
, but it makes a copy, and that copy has
some variation.
So you get something different, and that
organism might be better fit to the
environment, or worse fit.
If it's a worse fit, it's going to die
out.
So it's going to be weeded out.
That template of information is going to
be weeded out of the population.
And the organisms that are well adapted
get to make more copies of themselves.
So what's going on in this process is
that you're building up information in an
organism and that information corresponds
to adaptations.
And so that information is information
that is predictive about the environment.
.
So organisms are performing inference
from the very beginning of life's
emergence.
They're trying to solve a problem.
It's how to stop this order to disorder
transition.
Basically, for an organism to stay
organized, it has to find energy.
And if it has to find and that's what
Schrodinger's book, what his Life was
showing, is that life resists this
tendency to fall apart that Boltman
described, because it captures energy.
And that energy allows the system to do
work that's keeping the organization.
So with these phase transitions, you get
different memory systems building on each
other.
So you have genetic memory with the
origin of life.
Then you have neural memory with the
emergence of brains, and then you have
the emergence of civilization, and you
get cultural memory, and then you get
meme propagation.
So you get a different mode of
transferring information.
And all of these memory systems build on
each other and they all encode predictive
information about the environment that
allows the living system to stay out of
thermodynamic equilibrium, to stay out,
to prevent falling apart.
So one thing that is worth mentioning is
this new picture of hierarchical
emergence, this new paradigm where you
have this multilevel level nature of
reality, where reality is organizing
itself into these hierarchical levels.
It has predictive power.
That the reductionist theory.
Any reductionist theories of everything
don't have those are microphysics
theories and they don't apply to life.
So those theories of everything, I would
argue, aren't theories of everything
because they don't include life and
civilization and consciousness.
And what I'm saying is that that stuff
has causal power.
It's not epithet phenomena.
So any theory of everything needs to
include those things because they
consider them epid phenomena.
They go, we don't have to worry about it.
.
But what I'm saying is those things
actually have causal power and they need
to be explained.
So some predictive power that this theory
has that the old model doesn't, this
microscale model is that we can actually
use the dynamics of a system at one level
to understand the dynamics of a system at
another level because they're isomorphic.
.
They have similar patterns because they'
're all complex adaptive systems.
So what I'm saying is that you can make
predictions and you can use principles to
optimize society that are the same
principles at work in evolution that
optimize organisms.
And so we can think about someone's
asking, okay, maybe you accept that there'
's a global brain.
You go, okay, we are agents.
We're informationally connected.
We're exchanging information the way
neurons exchange signal each other
through action potentials.
We must be forming this collective
intelligence the way that there's an
intelligence in the brain.
And we know we are because that's how we
build rockets and stuff.
A single person doesn't do it.
We build on accumulated knowledge.
We stand on the shoulder of giants and we
share information.
That's what science is all about.
It depends on that.
So if you want to ask how intelligent is
the global brain, is the network of
humans, then you can fall back on
understanding the way that
neuroscientists have understand brains
and what leads to greater computational
power in brains?
Or what's the most robust design for a
civilization?
Well, what's the most robust design for
an organism?
Well, we want it to be hierarchical
because you have this division of labor
and all these other advantages that we'll
talk about in a minute.
So my point is this theory allows us to
predict things that we couldn't predict
before, because we are using a model of a
similar system, of a complex system at
one level to tell us things about what
hasn't happened in the future and what
will emerge.
And so there is an aspect of determinism
here.
It's not the same kind of determinism,
but there's a global determinism where
you get expected patterns at these levels.
.
So we can get a glimpse into where the
future is headed, but we can never know
the details and we can never know what
will emerge.
Exactly.
But we can see that these phase
transitions happen and we will get new
emergences.
Talking about predictive power.
So Paul Krugman Nobel prize winning
economist said, by 2005, it will become
clear that the Internet's impact on the
economy has been no greater than the fax
machines.
Probably the most wrong statement that
you could ever make.
And so why did he make this mistake?
Here we see it again.
Internet may be just a passing fad as
millions give up on it.
Why did they make this mistake?
What I'm saying is, if they had this
framework that I've just outlined, we
would have known when we saw the Internet.
.
This is a tool for interconnection.
This is a tool for complexification.
It's not going away.
Maybe the Internet would go away, but
something else with a different name
would replace it because this is part of
this trajectory that Ray Kurzwell called,
like, the destiny for life.
So without this theory, we will not see
obvious things that would be obvious to
us otherwise.
And we'll make terrible predictions like
Paul Krugman, and hopefully everybody
reminds him every day of his life that he
made that prediction.
He's really into systems thinking.
And so I think he would understand this.
And I'm interested to know whether he got
into systems thinking after he made that
prediction or before.
Because if you see this picture, like
Kilhardeshardin's newest fear, he
predicted this, the Internet, like 100
years ago based on his theory becoming
more integrated.
So what does this mean for society?
We'll mention some of that stuff before
getting into the Bayesian stuff just
because it's here.
Isolationism is bad.
We want to be connected.
If you cut people off, it's not good.
There's no information exchange.
And it could be good for your nation in
the short term, but eventually what's
happening elsewhere in the world is going
to affect you because it's one integrated
system.
So we want to connect to people because
we want to open up channels of
information exchange, but we also want to
preserve nations.
We want to have this hierarchical thing
where there's control centers at all of
these levels towns, cities, nations, et
cetera.
So we don't want it to become a
homogenized hive mind.
Why?
Because complexity is in computational
power.
It's a function of variety and
integration.
So something is more complex, has more
computational power if there's more
diversity among the parts and if there's
more connections between those parts.
So that definition of complexity that
lets us know if an organism is more
complex, like a human brain is more
complex than an ant brain because it has
more neurons and more connections and
more hierarchical levels, we can use that
to create a more robust society.
Now, what does this mean for you?
It means life is part of a cosmic process
with a goal.
There's this cosmic attractor, and we're
agents that are part of that bringing
that attractor about this process allows
the universe to wake up.
So life spreading is the inanimate world
finding a form that models itself, and
slowly the universe starts.
To become this integrated network that's
this coherent intelligence.
So that's pretty interesting spiritual
implications to that, however you want to
interpret that.
But when we're part of this, what does it
mean for us?
Okay, so this is the framing of the free
energy principle.
It says organisms are so saving it for
last, so it'd be climactic.
So the free energy principle, it frames
it with this schrodinger framing.
And Carl Friston, that's where he got it
from.
And it's also influenced by cybernetics.
But if you look at that stuff, you have
the free energy principle because it
basically says all organisms will fall
apart, all ordered systems.
So free energy principle applies to
aliens.
Any organized system anywhere in this
universe will have to, first of all,
extract energy if they want to stay
organized.
Free energy principle doesn't focus on
that.
But even though it has free energy in the
name but I will focus on that because I
think it should be a part of it.
Organisms have to capture real
thermodynamic free energy to stay in the
game of existence, to capture energy from
a chaotic external world, you have to
start modeling the world.
And that evolution is building a model of
the world through variation and selection,
, through these accumulation of
adaptations.
And then brains do it even better.
And then you can update the model in real
time with brains because you have
synaptic plasticity.
It's not slow, where things have to die.
And you have this phylogenetic learning,
which is like the population is learning
this individuals can learn in real time.
And so you have to model the world.
And the free energy principle, that's
what it says.
It says there's reality and it has all
these details that we don't know, and we
have to create a model or a map of that
world that's a coarse grain, simplified
version of that.
And then that model is going to have
errors.
And so what the free energy principle and
active inference framework says is that
when we're doing actions in the world,
those are like miniature experiments.
And what we should do if we want to live
optimally and stay out of thermodynamic
equilibrium.
If we want to survive and be robust, we
want to decrease the difference between
our model of the world, we want to
decrease the error of our model and we
want to make it more of an accurate
representation of the world.
So you have reality and then you have a
model of reality.
And when you want your model to match
reality as close as you can, to be able
to extract energy and avoid threats and
to stay in existence so we can be part of
this continual process of
complexification.
So we only got ten more minutes, but I
think we can actually cover all this.
So this looks really complex, but this is
going to allow me to explain the free
energy principle and merge it with
evolutionary theory and even the process
of science.
So this is an organism imagine this is
the first organism that emerged with the
origin of life.
And so this organism makes copies of
itself, and you get all of these
different designs, right?
So these different designs are variations
on this model.
This organism is an embodied theory about
how to survive, about how to stay far
from equilibrium.
So it has a predictive model of the world
that makes copies of itself, and you get
all of these competing predictive models,
and then these models compete for
survival, and some die out.
And the winning design is the best
predictor.
It gets to make copies of itself, and you
get a similar design.
So what's going on here is you have
models that are competing models, the way
scientific models compete.
And Bayes theorem is basically you have a
theory, and you have competing models,
and then you make predictions with those
models, and then you test those
predictions, and you update the
probability that each model is true based
on the results of those experiments.
And so you want to update your model
based on new evidence.
And so what I'm saying is, evolution,
when you create all these organisms,
these copies, and they compete, it's
competing models, the way that scientific
theories compete.
And the winning model is a product of
natural selection, the same way that the
winning scientific theory is a product of
surviving criticism and testing.
So that's a natural selection pressure.
So as these generations go on, with each
generation, you get an update to the
model.
It's a Bayesian update.
And so the model starts to match reality
better, such that after a bunch of
generations, you get an optimized
organism that's optimized for that niche.
.
And so this is how evolution itself is a
process of Bayesian inference.
As organisms adapt, they're updating
their model.
Karl Friston has understood this
equivalence and says that all of
evolution is inference.
Of course, someone might say all
inference is evolution, and it would all
be equally true.
But so this model applies to science.
It applies to learning.
So instead of all these different
organisms, which we said could be
theories, different competing models, you
could have this as different models of
maybe you're trying to figure out how to
play your sport to the best of your
ability, and you want to test out these
different things, and then you test them,
and one performs better.
And so that's the free energy principle,
is that you're decreasing the difference
between your model and actual reality.
So you're doing these little experiments
all the time, and based on what works,
you're updating your model, or you should
be if you want to optimize your system
for survival and growth.
And so it's the same when we're trying to
find a political philosophy capitalism,
socialism.
These are competing models.
We test those models out.
This is variation in selection.
And the ones that work, they get retained
by society, and we keep those.
So capitalism, I would argue it's
terrible right now, but it was the best
model for the time.
And the superior model is always going to
be it's never going to be one thing.
It's always going to change.
So we would want to test hybrids between
socialism and capitalism and crypto
economics.
If you want to determine a political
party based on this, what you would say
was that the best solution for a
political party is to try out different
models in small areas and based on what
works, then you can see where to apply
those models.
But I would argue that it's not going to
be socialism for every place.
It's not going to be capitalism.
It might not even be a hybrid.
It might even be something in addition to
that, like crypto economics.
And that we have to test these things.
And if we're not testing them and we're
not trying these different models, we're
not living optimal.
We have no way to get to the optimal
worldview political philosophy if we're
not doing.